what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are getting into the origin
of the orange lanterns also known as
Agent Orange now here's the cool thing
about this this is the last Prelude that
we cover before we finally get into
blackest night I'm pretty sure it is
although now that I think about it I
think emerald eclipse it might be the
last pretty loo that we do I'll have to
double check and make sure I've looked
at my schedule earlier and I'm pretty
sure as emerald Eclipse but in terms of
the Lantern course the orange lantern in
truth I would argue probably the most
powerful of the Lantern course and the
only reason for this isn't the nature of
the core itself its how the core is used
but before we get into that what we do
here is we pick up with a group called
the controllers now the controller's
first appeared in adventure comics
number 357 I think it was back in 1967
and they were an offshoot of the
guardians of the universe now if you're
just now joining us with regards to all
our Green Lantern mythos and our Green
Lantern stuff the guardians of the
universe are this extremely old race
they've been alive for billions and
billions of years they were originally a
race called the Malthusians and the idea
was that one of their member a guy by
the name of Corona wanted to witness the
beginning of all things the problem with
this was that in doing so he basically
created the antimatter universe or the
origin of evil in the DC Universe and
the result is that that led to the
events that eventually became crisis on
Infinite Earths
now the idea here is that with the
controller's themselves what they ended
up doing is where some of the Malthusian
some of the women broke off and became
the zamarons who were basically the
creators of the star sapphires Lantern
core the controllers broke off and then
they just kind of isolated different
sections of the universe for the most
part they were background characters now
what this does is it brings in to the
idea that there were sections of the
universe that the Green Lantern's were
not allowed to enter and they were not
allowed to enter under the ruling of the
guardians of the universe when the
guardians of the universe made the Green
Lantern Corps they'd already been around
for quite some time and the idea was
that for whatever reason no one could
ever enter the Vega system now we end up
having the controllers enter this area
and when they do it's just kind of this
disembodied voice talking about how the
guardians of the universe broke their
promise the guardians of the universe
betrayed them the controller's
themselves want to basically defeat the
guardians of the universe take their
rightful place as the ruler of
universe and they believe they can
achieve this by basically capturing the
orange light of avarice the greed aspect
of the emotional spectrum now remember
if you're new to this when it comes to
the Green Lantern mythos originally it
was just the Green Lantern's
and then Sinestro who had a yellow
lantern right the idea with geoff johns
in terms of him revamping it all was to
basically come along and say there is
something called the emotional spectrum
and the emotional spectrum is basically
it really just kind of exists as an
extension of all emotion that exists in
the universe so as long as there are
people who feel rage fear people who
feel hope those aspects of the emotional
spectrum will always be there greed is
one of the aspects of the emotional
spectrum but where the Green Lantern
Corps has you know all these different
members who exist to serve as a police
force because this is the emotion of
greed there's only ever one member of
the orange lantern court now we don't
initially see who this guy is instead
the controllers are just kind of set
upon by all these orange constructs and
effectively just ripped to pieces now
what this does is this comes out of the
last video that we did where we
basically covered the blue lanterns
again the blue lanterns are the lantern
court of hope now a lot of people look
to the blue lanterns and say in terms of
overall course which is to say cores
that consist of more than one person the
blue lanterns are the most powerful and
in a lot of ways they are just because
of the different abilities they have the
kind of things that they can do they're
more of a support Lantern Corps but
again all the lanterns have their
caveats a Blue Lantern ring is basically
useless it's not really effective unless
it's in the presence of a Green Lantern
and the reason for that is because the
blue lanterns were created by ganthet
and sayd two of the guardians of the
universe who believed in the idea that
the prophecy of blackest night was going
to come true which is to say a war
between all the lantern cores in order
to prepare for this war of light they
created the blue lanterns the problem
with this is that they were outcasts in
the guardians of the universe they were
basically banished and so the idea that
Hal Jordan is essentially bonded with a
Blue Lantern ring and a Green Lantern
ring is basically this idea that the
original indications seem to be that he
was going to be the leader of the Blue
Lantern Corps the problem with this is
that with him having this ring he can't
just remove it in fact there's basically
an effect on this ring that he can't
remove it until he's able to wield the
Lantern ring now this is really just
design to
allow Hal Jordan to tap into the various
aspects of the emotional spectrum and
that's really what geoff johns was
shooting for when he did this keep in
mind when it comes to the Green Lantern
mythos in DC Hal Jordan is front and
center he's the front runner to all that
and so the idea here is that Geoff Johns
was working on this ideology of
basically having Hal Jordan go through
all these different experiences with the
lantern rings and what that would do is
it would give the reader a clearer
understanding of what the Rings were
capable of because it's one thing to see
like the indigo see you know suddenly
show up and use their Lantern rings and
so on and so forth and then it's another
to have Hal Jordan become one of their
lanterns and then basically give us an
explanation of what the ring is capable
of but with this whole situation he
simply just again cannot remove the ring
and so at this point he's just trying to
cope with it as best he can now what
also ends up happening here is he
actually bails out for the purpose of
trying to find Sinestro so again all
this really kind of comes to a head
leading up to this massive war of light
this huge you know blackest night event
that's going to take place the problem
with this is that as soon as Hal Jordan
takes off on his mission he's
immediately brought before the other
members of the guardians of the universe
who look at him and say you've been
tainted by ganthet and sayd they are
outcasts you are not to associate with
them one thing to keep in mind is the
guardians of the universe play the Green
Lantern's pretty close to the vest
there's not a lot of wiggle room for
Green Lantern's to kind of do what it is
that they want to do there's a very
strict set of rules but the Green
Lantern's have to follow they can't use
their rings for selfish purposes they
have to use them for the purpose of
operating as police more or less or I
guess a protective force in the DC
Universe now of course with the
guardians of the universe more or less
trying Hal Jordan or the very least
intending to basically remove the Blue
Lantern ring from him some of the Green
Lantern's basically travelling back with
a piece of the orange lantern itself
what this ends up revealing is the
presence of Larfleeze
now Larfleeze is super powerful but
before we get into why what we ended up
doing here is basically having this
explanation that there was a deal that
was struck more or less between the
Guardians of the Universe and Larfleeze
they stay away he stays away everybody
stays fine it's just a totally neutral
thing what ended up happening is that
with the controllers entering into the
Vega system for the purpose of pursuing
the orange lantern light of greed
ended up happening is that Larfleeze
interpreted this as the Guardians
violating their their treaty basically
invading Pina pega system and the result
was that he looked at this as an act of
aggression and says fine if you attack I
attack too and that leads into his whole
presence here now one of the things that
we do is we actually switch over to a
character named fatality now all of this
goes all the way back to a story called
cosmic Odyssey and it was actually issue
number two and it was written by jim
Starlin in 1989 now this was kind of a
spacefaring story but one of the
elements was designed to focus on Jon
Stewart as a character keep in mind when
it came to the different Green Lantern's
first there was Hal Jordan then there
was John Stewart followed by Guy Gardner
and then eventually Kyle Rayner but Jon
Stewart's character being fleshed out
was again designed to make him more
human because remember when it came to
the Green Lantern mythos before the
whole original Green Lantern rebirth
story and this huge run by Geoff Johns
Green Lantern was always struggling to
sell DC always had one heck of a time
trying to get people to read his stories
and the result was that they began
bringing in different versions of the
Green Lantern's on earth really kind of
bringing in like Jon Stewart as a
companion of sorts to Hal Jordan for the
purpose of bringing in readers who
wouldn't normally read those stories the
idea here though was that this story
dealt with the anti-life equation of
course the anti-life equation being most
well known as a Jack Kirby creation and
basically serving as a means that if
somebody is able to decipher the
anti-life equation and harness it they
can dominate the wills of others but
what this ended up doing is it brought
both Jon Stewart and Martian Manhunter
to a planet called zhanchi
at least I think it's pronounced sonshi
it's XA in SH I I'm I assume that's how
it's pronounced but the idea here is
that with Saatchi what we ended up
finding out was that there was basically
this massive bomb and the core of the
planet but with Jon Stewart being a bit
reckless with Jon Stewart kind of
getting carried away with his powers to
a degree he ultimately was not able to
keep the bomb from detonating and the
result is that it wiped out the entire
planet of zon she destroyed all of its
native inhabitants now this was
important because the character of
fatality really her name being Yaris in
real I think is how you pronounce it she
was basically one of the members of this
planet of course she was off the world
at the time that had happened but the
idea was that Jon Stewart had basically
destroyed everything she knew and loved
and so from 1989 going up to the
I'm the story's written she had largely
served as this on-again off-again
villain of Jon Stewart in the sense that
she would pop up from time to time but
it was a way for DC to basically give
Jon Stewart his own version of Sinestro
and so because of this what ended up
happening is during Sinestro Corps war
because she was such a such an enemy of
Jon Stewart she became a member of the
Sinestro Corps this led into the end of
Sinestro Corps war itself she was
captured by the star sapphires and they
basically began modifying her for the
purpose of turning her into a star
sapphire and so again with star
sapphires being driven by love as the
one emotion they feel more than anything
else what this does is as soon as
fatality on a quest to basically find
Jon Stewart now of course this again
leads directly into the whole Vegas
system this basically results in the
guardians of the universe and Hal Jordan
along with the other Green Lantern's
seeking out Larfleeze because again at
this point Larfleeze is kind of this
unstable element he's kind of this guy
where no one really knows what he's
gonna do he's very much a variable in
this whole situation but despite
everything that's going on remember how
Jordan is largely plagued by the Blue
Lantern ring now for the most part it
works out in his benefit because
remember the Blue Lantern rings bolster
the power of the Green Lantern ring so
what this basically does is it basically
you know it really amplifies what it is
that he's able to do one ring charges
the other and so because of that is
constantly keeping his power at Absolute
max 100% of the time now of course when
they end up arriving on the Vega system
they're immediately met with these
orange constructs of Larfleeze and
that's the difference between the way
his Corps works and other course because
of the fact that Larfleeze is the only
member of the orange Lantern Corps what
he does is he basically kills people and
then duplicates their essence and turns
them into constructs what this does is
it gives him a limitless supply of
constructs to create so long as there
are people out there that he can kill
they get bolstered and added to his
Lantern Court now the other half of this
is that he's been doing this for quite
some time more so than that what ends up
happening is the Green Lantern's when
they face off against the orange Lantern
Corps they're basically facing off
against former friends and allies and
that's what makes this so difficult
because they're basically forced to
fight people they fought alongside at
one point along the line but that's the
nature of the Green Lantern's overcoming
fear and so in the face of all this what
they basically
have to do is come to grips with the
fact that these constructs as they exist
are not the people that they knew and
there's no way to get them back they're
effectively gone now at the same time
because of the fact that Hal Jordan is
wielding a blue Lantern ring Larfleeze
of course tries to acquire it for
himself and that's the other half of the
story when it comes to his character
Larfleeze with all the power that he
possesses quite literally takes on the
entirety of the guardians of the
universe and the Green Lantern Corps all
at the same time and the reason why is
because as the only orange Lantern
he's mainlining those powers remember
he's greedy he keeps everything to
himself and of course we'll find out why
here in a little bit he would never
trust his orange lantern is a-- his
orange central power battery to anybody
else what this means is that with the
green lantern for example the Green
Lantern central power battery operating
as the source of energy for all the
green lanterns that exists out in the
universe if you were to take that you
know Green Lantern central power battery
you were to take all the other Green
Lantern's powers away and then you were
to plunge that Green Lantern central
power battery into a singular person
they would be almost unstoppable and in
fact that's a statement of the guardians
of the universe make what they do is
they basically say Larfleeze is a threat
on par with Hal Jordan when he was
parallax
now for those of the guys who were new
and you don't know what that means back
in 1993 when BC was basically trying to
revamp the Green Lantern mythos and look
to kill off Hal Jordan and replace him
with Kyle Rayner what they did is they
lost a story called Emerald Twilight and
this came out of the death of Superman
following Superman being killed at the
hands of doomsday a cyborg superman rose
to prominence and in a longside one of
Superman's most notable enemies a guy
named Mongol attacked ko City the home
of Hal Jordan now Hal Jordan was off the
planet at the time that happened but
when he came back he found out that
everything that he knew and loved was
totally destroyed now initially he coped
with it as best he could by using his
Lantern ring to recreate everything
around him this of course violated the
laws of the guardians of the universe in
that you can't use a ring for selfish
purposes he was brought back to OA he
was chastised he lost his mind wiped out
all the Green Lantern's that were in
existence was possessed by parallax the
living embodiment of fear and then
basically won on this crusade to try to
blink the multiverse out of existence
and bring it back he was absolutely nuts
but the big takeaway from all this is
that how
Jordan as parallax was one of the most
if not the most powerful being in
existence at that time Larfleeze seems
to be on par with that now this is in
terms of the power that he can use what
he can create I wouldn't go as far as to
say that Larfleeze can basically try to
destroy the universe it's entirely
possible but there's no reason to
believe that that's true at the time
this story is being written with regards
to Agent Orange but again because of the
fact that he's so obsessed with
collecting things for himself with all
the power that he has what we also end
up finding out here is that the orange
lantern ring the orange constructs
created by large fleas himself have the
ability to absorb constructs of other
lantern cores and so essentially what's
happening is the Green Lantern's at
guardians of the universe they're
fighting off Larfleeze as best they can
but none of their weapons have any real
impact and so the result of all this is
that Larfleeze is basically running amok
on these guys he's absolutely wrecking
these guys and so the result is that
Wally's constructs are out fighting
against the guardians of the universe
he basically gives a story to Hal Jordan
but something that I want you to take
note of when it comes to these
constructs is that they're not really
being controlled directly by Larfleeze
and that's one of the other big
differences here when Larfleeze conjures
is constructs they function according to
the will of Larfleeze
but they do it in their own capacity if
Larfleeze says I want those guys to die
any conjures constructs those constructs
can think for themselves they're
sentient they can do what it is they
want to do but they'll be driven by the
motivation to kill whoever it is that
Larfleeze wants to see dead what we end
up finding out here is that Larfleeze
and a handful of other guys were
basically scavengers / thieves but the
idea was that they were in the midst of
this heist because supposedly there was
rumor that there was a treasure so great
that even the guardians of the universe
would seek it out that they would covet
that now once they went to this treasure
room once they basically located it they
ended up finding out this was the orange
lantern ring no we're not explicitly
told how that Lantern ring got there but
the idea is that because this represents
the greed aspect of the emotional
spectrum as soon as all four guys lay
eyes on it they're immediately driven by
the desire to covet it for themselves
this of course leads to the arrival of
the guardians of the universe who
realize what's going on
but with Larfleeze harnessing the
central power battery on his own what
this does is it leads to him just going
on an app's
rampage and so the result of this was
that a bargain was struck between the
guardians of the universe and largely is
again like we said earlier the Guardians
stay away largely stays away they never
allow Green Lantern's to go to that area
the only people who do go through there
are those who just kind of stumble make
mistakes and just happen to cross the
path of Larfleeze after which almost
none of them are ever seen or heard from
again Larfleeze will kill them and then
just hoard whatever it is they have he's
literally the epitome of a hoarder but
the idea here is that with Larfleeze
essentially seeming to overcome Hal
Jordan he quite literally takes the Blue
Lantern ring away from him what we end
up finding out is that this is actually
a ruse the Blue Lantern ring basically
protected itself like creating kind of a
telepathic image the idea here is that
the Blue Lantern ring tricks Larfleeze
into believing that he actually has
access to it when he really doesn't now
of course this results in Hal Jordan
basically bolstering his Green Lantern
ring using the Blue Lantern ring and
then just attacking Larfleeze as best he
can but again there's no absolute way
for them to win here because Larfleeze
is so powerful and so in the midst of
all this how Jordan does the only thing
he can do and literally takes the orange
power battery away which is kind of a
cool thing but this is again another
example that we were talking about with
geoff johns basically having Hal Jordan
cure these roles of the different
Lantern courts in this instance with him
acquiring the orange Lantern central
power battery the result is that he
immediately has overcome by greed in
every sense of the word he wants to eat
everything he wants to collect
everything he wants absolute power he's
driven by the desire to gather
everything around him this is my central
power battery no one can have it as
absolutely mine that's what makes this
so cool is because again the emotional
spectrum is designed to represent these
various emotions that people feel the
other half of this is that with
Larfleeze
again being the only person who has
access to the central power battery of
the orbs Lantern court what he ends up
doing is just super charging himself and
so where the ring normally functions at
like 100 percent capacity or something
along those lines he's super charges at
70 times over basically bringing it to a
charge of seven thousand times more
powerful than it normally is I guess
seventy times more powerful than it
normally is at seven thousand percent
we're talking about a level of power
that almost no one really seems to be
able to cope with
no one really seems to be able to do
anything with now again this brings in
the second aspect of the blue lantern
link because of Luo Lantern ring kept
chiming in and saying what is it that
you hope for how Jordan basically
responds by saying I hope you stop
asking me that question now this is a
big deal when it comes to the Blue
Lantern rings and as part of that whole
caveat that a person constantly has to
feel hope when you're imbued with a Blue
Lantern ring you have to feel legitimate
true and untainted ho which is to say
you genuinely believe what it is that
you're hoping for so again with this
idea of how Jordans saying I hope it
will stop asking me this question it's
legitimate hope now it doesn't mean that
like his wildest dreams are gonna come
true what it means is it allows him to
tap into the Blue Lantern ring now this
hope that he feels is contextual right
like you know if he if for example how
Jordan were to say I really like having
this Blue Lantern ring then he wouldn't
hope to be rid of it anymore and the
result is that his hope would have to
shift to something else he would have to
hope for something and then use that as
the anchor that keeps him connected to
the Blue Lantern ring but in this moment
right now because of the fact that he's
able to tap into the ring in its full
power what it does is it reveals that
the Blue Lantern ring is immune to the
effects of avarice it's immune to the
orange Lantern ring and that's why this
is so powerful because when it comes to
the blue lanterns beer designed to
basically oppose all forms of evil and
so the idea is that in addition to
opposing all forms of evil and at the
same time offering itself as a support
role to all forms of good it's basically
the backbone of almost all the Lantern
cores and that's why it's so important
that's why it's so powerful it's the
foundation by which almost all these
houses set and so the result is that
while he feels it momentarily while
Larfleeze is basically overcome when
this is done when it's over with the
ring basically takes off that was the
condition the ring would leave as soon
as Hal Jordan was able to wield it but
again this is part of that whole idea of
ganthet and sayd these two exiled
members of the guardians of the universe
looking to the future basically saying
if this war of light is going to happen
then it's important that Hal Jordan
among all others be exposed to these
various Lantern cores so that he knows
how to deal with them accordingly and so
because of this when everything
basically winds down and it comes to an
end they're gone into the universe
strike another bargain
Larfleeze were not initially told what
this Morgan is instead the green
lanterns are basically sent back the
guardians of the universe traveled back
to OA and we end up finding out that the
request that was made by Larfleeze was
to know the location of the Blue Lantern
Court now again this works out for the
guardians of the universe the ones that
are currently occupying it because
remember with ganthet and sayd being
exiles they've basically been branded as
heretics as people who are fear mongers
the idea that they're espousing this
whole war of light blackest night it
goes directly in line with what the
normal guardians of the universe are
trying to do which is basically ignore
the war of life and so what this does is
it allows them to kill two birds with
one stone if they send Larfleeze over to
the Blue Lantern port most likely it'll
be a it'll be a conflict that will see
deaths on both sides
even if Larfleeze is defeated and not
all the blue lanterns die it could
result in the death of ganthet and sayd
which means there would be nobody left
to make any blue lanterns not only that
it would probably also see the wholesale
slaughter of the blue lanterns
themselves and so it would basically
allow the existing guardians of the
universe to wipe out those they consider
to be adversaries and one fell swoop
it'll literally just bring them all out
you know it'll it'll just take them all
out in their entirety so again this is
really just kind of house sinister some
of these guardians are it's really how
they look at the things around them and
say it's time to basically bring
everything under our wing and to carve
the universe out in a way that we
perceive to be at existing in our image
but with that being said guys we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explain and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
pork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]